is getting mobile right a live or die
issue for Yahoo I think that it's a
really critical issue it was certainly
one of the biggest missed opportunities
that that I saw when I came through the
reading a very few people working on it
when we got there not we have hundreds
of people working on it we've made big
advances we started to see just you know
mobile is approximately doubling along
every metric we have in terms of traffic
revenue users we're up to 430 million
monthly unique users on mobile so we
have the largest mobile audiences in the
world already and I think that when I
think about the opportunity when you
think about it was really interesting we
pulled a list of what people do on their
phones and with a few key deletions you
could actually read the list and feel
like you were describing Yahoo's
business it was like mail maps news
share photos flickr pictures games group
communication sports you get the idea of
watching videos and so we were in all of
those areas and so now it's a matter of
taking the content the services we have
online and bringing them onto the phone
in a really meaningful way